what is going on there reject nation g
and john here today we are going to
watch the latest episode of the bad
batch guys subscribe and click you know
what screw all that crap but i will say
this full length watch along is on
patreon and there's a bunch of other
shows there too don't screw that crap
that's good crap that's good crap don't
screw it eat it you know who gives good
crap
berthom jindal for editing these
highlights for us he gives the biggest
crowd craps them together like nobody
else
now i'm excited let's see what's in
store we're nearing the end people come
on let's go
[Music]
war mantle
that is gorgeous
that's a clone trooper yeah
that's the same who's this one
so it's like jurassic park
keep going man
take a break man sleep it off
oh [ __ ] were those stormtroopers it
looked like it yeah
i received a distress signal from a
clone trooper but i'm a bit tied up at
the moment to retrieve him
you want us to recover a reg he's an old
friend
and he's in trouble which one is it
what exactly
talk right now sending you a signal i'll
be in touch
the distress signal sent by cc5576
is originating from dara with no known
settlements or installations
what's he doing all the way out there
well does it matter
rex wouldn't ask us for help if it
wasn't urgent echo's got a point
we are in the middle of a job for sid if
we deviate we will not be compensated
no money means no food
that's more important
wow the kid's gonna
help rex you know you want it that goes
fine
yep we'll check things out i don't like
it
no pissed echo would be and sure every
viable clone is mobilized
you know the darker the show gets the
better it
the kamen allens we have our orders keep
an eye on them
until the time is right i don't like
this
we'll still be soldiers won't we of
course
that is what you were made for now let's
say
really loves the kids i will join you
later
join you in the afterlife maybe the
empire has cancelled all of our
contracts
yep the empire is not like the republic
we have empowered them to our own
detriment
destroy us rather than allow this
operation to continue
sounds right we're banking a lot on a
clone we don't even know
rex trusts him and i'd trust wrecks
the beacon should be right ahead found
it
[Music]
so where's this rake hot tutter
hunt you were born for the jungle my
friend
we're already too late the clone was
being hunted
and was dragged way
there's something here inside that
mountain
this is cool my scans are being jammed
you said there was nothing on this
planet that data appears to be
inaccurate maybe there's something
in this planet wait what coming here was
up for debate
this isn't just take
the ship flying around omega you've
learned how to pilot
kind of yeah keep to keep the motor
running getaway driver
what exactly is in that mountain well
only one way to find out look it up
wikipedia
[Music]
so this is like the painting this
episode this is the bob ross
every episode every moment just gonna
look freaking gorgeous
little happy little imperial base this
looks like some sort of
military base not one that i've ever
heard of
[Music]
i'm trying to guess who this clone is i
have
one guess better get it out there before
we see the reveal
i'm clocking a couple of commandos
squads of clone troopers
and they've updated their armor this is
no longer just a simple extraction
let's get back to the marauder and leave
wood for ricks but what about the
mission
we do not know for certain if cc5576 is
even in there
we'd be going in blind without any
reinforcements
i like those odds if there's a chance
that troopers being held against his
will
we have to try to get him out oh that's
great
well they brought that back i'll need to
tap into the central database to
pinpoint
cz5576's location there are entry points
we can access in the lift shaft
that's our way in
speaking of
oh man cool
this is such a cool episode
get ready to jump
huh
this kind of feels like a new hope yeah
good call
[Music]
that just looks like a death star
doesn't it like the inside of one
seeing the the empire arrive at their
aesthetic ear marks
yeah going for black and gray
i've got some swatches here
[Music]
don't worry guys they suck at shooting
maybe he'll be good at shooting he's got
the special blue visor exactly
it's all about aim get me some food
quiet trigger that's captain trader
insubordinate plebe plebe
ucc 5576 that depends
who's asking rex sent us
in that case the name is gregor i knew
it
i should have said it damn it i told you
i was like
no it's the one who has a name that
sounds like mine
[Laughter]
damn okay i believe you i believe
that's why i remember his name because
that's all the name of sounds like
this is your boy it's your episode right
now
a long hallway yeah i'mma like that
i take it your cc's like me
ct99s defective clones
only one way out up love his voice
these are not clone troopers no look how
hot this guy is
these are our replacements if you can
believe that yeah they're used to the
exact music oh that's awesome
i thought you said you trained these
guys i didn't teach them everything
i wouldn't be very smart would it we
have gregor to blame for all this
yeah for their terrible aim we taught
them everything they know
these recruits come from all over the
galaxy and swear
loyalty to the empire they're not as
skilled
but there's an endless supply of them
numbers out everything is that the truth
that's clever numbers aren't everything
i'm charging up before i charge in
we should have heard from them by now
what if something went wrong
i'm sure they got everything under
control like we always do every week
yeah yeah take that
that guy looks strangely familiar
okay he's extra strong because he's got
special armor
the yellow armor yeah stood out
that's a character tell me who it is
isn't it a class of trooper don't worry
about me
this is nothing i got blown up once and
survived
i can survive this cupola was
i was sent here with other commandos and
quickly realized
i wanted out if it turns out the empire
doesn't take too kindly to desertion
they're escaping to the reactor port i
love the music in this show
so much look how beautiful that is wow
glad we're not going that way we are on
approach
we see you oh so did that oh god
so do they oh god no
[Music]
no it's like the future
do it or make a fly jump closer
no no oh man no
i can't code it that is sufficient i'll
take it
here wrecker i love the early model
looks of these things
oh the one stormtroopers set a chance
no that that they shoot
[Laughter]
damn look at them go oh yeah
do a barrel roll donkey
we need you come on donkey
it's working systems are back online
wow wow
so awesome my nipples are so chilly
right now
oh no nice one
we're coming back around be ready
stand there romeo oh yeah omega don't
get clipped
ah sound effect
no what just happened
ah
conscious maybe he is
yeah he's just got a concussion it'll be
fun
[Music]
oh boy
oh [ __ ] just
oh man get the ship out of here i'll
find another way back
negative the odds of escape are not in
your favorite
[Music]
wow he's gonna get left
sorry kid i can't do that
oh man wow
oh a disturbing matter has been brought
to my attention
[Music]
your chief scientist was gathering
medical personnel
to flee kamino i will ensure a
proper punishment while i never found
your clone troopers to be overly
impressive
i do believe you will be of great
service to the empire
a scientist i have use for a politician
i do not
wow
oh no oh god
goodbye prime minister
now you guys just gotta go in there
rescue hunter
they just keep swapping out you broke in
once you can do it again
[Music]
oh yeah you'd show up what's up
crosshair
oh [ __ ] man i was helping for the whole
squad
but you do
[Music]
that was the best episode so far yeah
that was pretty awe that was incredible
beginning to end i was that that was the
most enthralled i've ever been with a
bad batch episode
that was that was awesome hell yeah i
felt like cinematic
i really loved the hell out of that one
feel like a star wars movie you know
yeah what a weird concept
our comedy yeah
man that [ __ ] was awesome it was
awesome uh greg gregor
i think he's i don't remember if he's in
clone wars at all you guys can clarify
that for me i'm sure he's been in an
episode or two at some point
um but yeah rebels is where he's mainly
known from uh
he's in like the he's old okay
rebels takes place after all the other
animated shows
uh yeah rebels takes place after bad
batch and
um yeah he's uh i don't i don't remember
the full background on him or exactly
what landed him to be working with rex
down here but it looks like they are
filling in some of the gaps here
of what led to them um
growing old together working together
and such a beautiful room but here in
the left
and then yeah that has not every most
clones names i've forgotten
but that name always stood out to me
because it's my name with one missing
letter
absolutely it's the archaic for you
there's no
john's i mean maybe there is john is too
generic to name to be in any star war
it's so amazing gregor it would sound
like my name
a john would have to be like jonathan or
something like that
probably you guys comment down below um
but yeah uh in terms of
just an overall episode it felt the one
of the more cinematic ones normally when
that batch goes dark uh they feel more
cinematic but this from
tonally from beginning to end you could
just feel
the tension rising and i love like the
suspicion
of the events as they're uncovering
everything like
the the episode has such a good prologue
to it
with uh um gregor getting captured
um and as he's like a clone running away
and then
it's like do you see the stormtrooper
feet come in like this is the
transitional period
of it all the their replacements coming
in showing the threat they are
that we know the stormtroopers to be
here right are they called stormtroopers
i don't think they're are they labeled
stormtroopers yet by this point
no i think they just called them tk
troopers at this moment yes
okay they're at the beginning storm
troopers that's what they have the proto
storm troopers
they'll be starting troopers soon enough
but yeah like everything just has this
big
mystery for them to uncover of dealing
with
what the rise of the empire is not
knowing the gravity of what the
empire is and then of course these like
beautiful shots throughout and the mood
they're striking but like as they're
going down
into it it looks like a death star
setting kind of reminds me of a new hope
and the sense you got these heroes going
in and then you gotta rescue someone
out of uh out of the little star wars
jail
you are going to star wars jail for
rebelling against the
empire that's what they do when you uh
try to unbuckle your
your seat too early on that galaxy's
edge on those rides they got there in
disneyland
so yeah um everything about it was just
so neat and then getting the presence of
gregor was very refreshing just with his
like
um his personality and deep bradley
baker just a different kind of voice on
him too
and yeah i was like they're all escaping
you really just feel the stakes i i
think the stakes are very much felt it's
got this real menacing undertone
throughout
you know john i left plenty for you to
talk about go take it away
i'm sorry yeah this one does kind of
help to bolster those stakes with the
way that it concludes with hunter
getting into
such a tight spot that they can't
maneuver out of it and he has to just
tell them to leave
because you know we lose everything
we've worked for today not just
me if you come back here we're just
outnumbered we're outmatched right now
we just found a secret military base
that none of us knew about and so yeah
feeling like you know we're headed
into the end of the season here like it
is gonna drive the stakes up heavily
because you know the batch is gonna have
to
come back in some way to where hunter
and crosshair both are
and have some kind of you know heavy
reunion and you know
we've been separated from crosshair
throughout the season and i
you know am at the point now where i'm
not even really
expecting as a foregone conclusion like
oh he's gonna
rejoin or have a change of heart or
they're gonna take his chip out or
something like
at this point it feels like it could go
any way to me
and so he opening it leaked he's going
to kiss him
oh dudes missed you so much
i've been cold and lonely
oh yeah i would i would so be here for
that i hope
that's the so you can't read those right
at least
but yeah no i and i agree with
everything else that you said about the
earlier parts of the episode
yeah it does have all the best elements
of
you know an imaginative setting but one
that is also like
super striking in like some of these
wide shots they choose to feature of
just how
like sharp that fall would be but also
how majestic the setting is and yeah
seeing these proto elements of the
what we will soon know to be the
imperial aesthetic and all that stuff
and yeah
seeing through the scope of the whole
season yeah the way that the empire
really
is slowly expanding itself and taking
hold and operating in these clandestine
spaces and yeah
it had all that sneaking and adventure
and whatnot but it also felt like we're
getting to a point where yeah something
uh ominous and and of you know great
consequence is
coming yeah you know and especially two
you now have the cameron owens you know
and their arrangement
being trampled on by admiral rampart and
the whole thing about like
you think that the doctor's gonna be the
one to get the ax when it turns out ah
we don't need politicians i mean we're
still gonna screw your plans up every
which way but
we're gonna do something even more
messed up and take your your
scientists and make her work for us um
so yeah i thought this was a
a rich one but man those nasty space
nazis are the worst
i thought the build up of the action was
especially well executed like those
aerial fight sequences
and the way like how you were talking
about just capturing the landscapes of
things but really showing you like
what levels they are throughout this
whole base of what is like super
imposing like just right down to when
they like get on the elevator ride down
have to leap off or you know hunter
jumping for omega's hand
but beyond that like the way they built
up the action with
they just they just kept getting
cornered it just kept getting tougher
and like they have that comment about
not everything's about numbers but you
see that they actually are kind of
threatening when you are over there like
storm troopers like the equivalent of
like zombie horde in a way you know like
the more they are the harder it is but
just one
or a few like maybe you could dodge them
yeah yeah
pretty easily but a lot is really
difficult to avoid if you cover yourself
in enough guts they can't smell you
either
so that is
hilarious thank you
i'm just gonna go excuse myself to the
great
comedy heaven
thanks for coming tip your waitress
[Laughter]
zombie horse yes uh dealing with the
dealing with the stormtrooper
that's funny i thought i thought we made
a good bit there yeah i'm glad we're
going
to be let's talk about our bit let's
review our bit no so at first it was a
bad joke going poorly and then they were
literally
hilarious that made it hilarious and
that's the real genius of greg albus
you can take [ __ ] and make it comedy
yeah crap that's the theme today crap
crap
and uh yeah so uh but yeah like i
thought the
the the the action scenes with like
all the piloting going on and then i
don't know what the gun is
oh like the the back i got one
like the turret yeah that one
that that all just hurt that looked the
most the action scene just felt
everything about this the word that
keeps coming to mind is cinematic
because it's
this reminded me of those fantastic
clone wars episodes you're like damn
this would have been great to see on a
big screen like that really captured it
this time around
and uh i you know you think they're
going to get away because you're kind of
used to the bad batch getting away yeah
and then so when hunter fell
like what the [ __ ] he's really falling
oh my god i couldn't believe it for a
second i was like
this isn't the structure of your show
what's going on here yeah
yeah it's like they said they let them
keep getting away in the nick of time
yeah second so you feel the snakes in
that second omega pops in like tell them
to come back you you we gotta come back
right i'm like oh no they're gonna do it
and then even having uh echo recall back
to what
got echo back in the star wars in the
first place
of when the bad batch was first
introduced and how rex
uh worked with the bad batch to go
rescue him and like they did the same
thing for him and they didn't even know
if they could trust echo if echo really
was a alive and if it
if echo is alive if he is a you know
someone we could trust didn't see him in
so long
so uh yeah like having like echo i
feel like no this is personal no matter
what especially for him
you know um yeah that was cool that was
great
that was a great great episode and the
music was top notch
uh they wow just so sweeping sweeping
swept up in this one yeah grab your
broom and sweep me up
toss me in the trash and put me in the
garbage dumpster crush me into a cube
and take me to a landfill
let me rot in the sun and turn into gas
to poison the earth
and thus the cycle puts your awoke
politics in our room i'm so sorry
everything's getting colder
guys what you think about this episode
leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click bells hit like buttons
if you enjoyed our video
what what we should do one more patron
of the day
shout out what for who for connor
because he
subscribed at the very end of the month
oh no way
yep grow that patron of the day graphic
hey connor connor thank god you caught
that notification
yeah i looked and i almost had a heart
attack but i was like good thing it's
still july
all right well connor my man we've been
wanting to shout you out
all month because we were like hey we
got to save the best for last
absolutely remember when i personally
message you saying dude
dude wait to pledge until the very end
of the month
just to mess with john as he's making a
little list of what we got to complete
and you really did it man killed the
game this this
show has all heroes journey written all
over the universe and you know who else
does
john connor see when i did connor
how great is that you put the two
together and my name is sarah
so what do you know i'm your mother if
john connor was split i don't i lost
sight of the shout out so we are both of
your dads
connor i hope that you are appreciative
of you got in just in time and this is
the reward i hope you're happy
hope you're happy because this is the
best shout out that we planned
all month yeah you rock dude next month
we'll do your initials
remember c stands for cool peace
you